I only furniture at this moment citria
establishing control over this continent
and every person on it
my allies are gone I'm losing you can
count on the iron back as soon as the
gold arrived enough with the clever plan
[Music]
new episode four footage let's break it
down so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm doing Game of Thrones all season
long there's a couple different scenes
that they broke up through the trailer
so I'll just go through this biased
storyline so Jon Snow and Daenerys on
the beach
she says enough of these clever plans
clearly directed at Tyrion who is clever
I drink and I know things but all of his
plans have gone to [ __ ] lately and I
think like a lot of the storylines and
the twists this season it's a
consequence of where they need the
characters and the plot to go so they
need the nearest to need Jon Snow's help
so they need to take her army away so
that's why Tyrion is a bad battle
commander because they're in Westeros he
should actually be way better at this
than Jaime and Cersei you see a
follow-up on that dragonglass Jon Snow
lights the torch and leaves Daenerys
into the caves underneath the Dragons
stone so they have this funny Goonies
thing going on where they're looking for
hidden treasure they're learning about
the Targaryen history learning about all
these supernatural things together
you can kind of see how Jon Snow doesn't
know anything about his Targaryen
heritage Daenerys doesn't know much
about dragonglass of the White Walkers
and they're just slowly learning all of
these things at the same rate so that by
the end of the season or by the
beginning of season 8 everybody will
have all the same information so if
you're frustrated that Daenerys has
absolutely no idea that dragonglass is
such a big thing it's just because
they're using that as a way for Jon Snow
to gain her trust and them to bond like
her learning about her heritage while
Jon Snow is getting the thing that he
needs so desperately so just like the
Dragons swooping by over John as he said
I'm not a stark continue to look for
more subtle references and winks at Jon
Snow secretly being a Targaryen as they
explore the caves of Dragonstone there
are more allies of convenience at this
point so I would just expect them to
grow closer over the next couple of
episodes because it seems like Jon's
going to be here for a while
but hopefully they don't brush over too
many of these character moments they've
kind of been doing that in the last
couple of episodes like where bran and
sanso have that scene and then she just
walks away after he tells her all this
information like wait now there's a lot
more we need to talk about that's mostly
just because they need to move the plot
so far along so it almost feels like
they're cramming 90 minutes of story
into 60 minutes of an episode so if you
feel like they're brushing over the
really cool stuff and that's probably
why does they need to move things along
so quickly which kind of sucks but
speaking of sucks Cersei is still
working with the iron bank securing
another loan she has to repay her debt
before they'll give her the money so
that's why Tyco new stores tells her
you'll get everything you want as soon
as they get back with the gold cut to
Jamie in the Lannister army traveling
down the Rose Road they're basically
travelling up this road to go back to
King's Landing so it's a location we
haven't seen before it looks pretty cool
but this is basically where they are
we'll see if they make it back safely
I mean the Dornish are still down here
we don't really know what their status
is because they killed the sand snakes
and the others are captive so who is
leading Dorne what happened to the army
that they were going to pick up there is
it still around the unsullied are going
to have to march all the way from
Casterly Rock
so maybe the Dornish army is still a
thing but it does seem like Cersei will
get the money that she wants from the
iron bank it seems like Theon makes it
back to Dragonstone and then you see all
these Winterfell scenes so Winterfell
and Dragons that are probably the two
most exciting places unless there's some
big battle that Jamie runs into while
he's traveling back to King's Landing
so Winterfell the big thing here you see
Arya on the horizon looking at it so one
Episode after brain arrives she arrives
so it's going to be fun to see how that
reunion plays out and I know Brienne is
going to town in this clip here but this
is just her training pod you see him in
this clip here on the ground later we
saw some behind the scenes of this he's
just trying to turn him into a better
fighter handing him his ass he's not
doing so hot but the more exciting
things that a lot of you were messaging
me with was this picture of what looks
like the cat's-paws Valyrian dagger in
Littlefinger's hand so yes they're very
clearly implying that Littlefinger is
going to pull a dagger on someone but
it's a bit misleading the way they cut
it because you see Sansa reading through
all of maester Luwin
copied Raven notes so every time a raven
was sent to or from Winterfell maester
Luwin copied it so the theory is is that
there's a record of Littlefinger's
correspondence with the Bolton's and
she'll learn of something really
treacherous that he was doing throwing
her under the bus when she was going
through all that crap with Ramsay that's
probably why the writers gave brand that
moment
tell Santa how he knew everything that
was happening telling her about her
wedding night which is this horrific
moment for her and bran just brushes
over it like it was the most beautiful
thing ever you in that beautiful white
dress as she slowly having a panic
attack remembering what happened that
night
so all those maester Luwin letters that
they were hinting at on last week's
episode probably have something to do
with that Littlefinger probably starts
scrambling a little bit arya comes back
you can do the math I feel like they're
going to team up to take Littlefinger
down he's my number one death prediction
for the season in terms of really big
characters but you guys can let me know
what do you think is going to happen
with Sansa reading these letters very
clearly she's going to learn something
that's really bad it is probably going
to turn her against Littlefinger if she
wasn't already sophie turner was saying
that salsa is wising up to Littlefinger
schemes so we don't really know what
kind of three-dimensional chess
Littlefinger's going to be playing in
this episode but typically like Varys
you expect him to be several moves ahead
of anybody he's going up against but
this season has been a little bit weird
with the way they have written the
characters so Littlefinger Varys just
not quite as smart or powerful if
they've been in previous seasons so I
feel like that's probably going to be
one of the big complaints of the episode
usually I can tell just looking from the
promo which storyline people will
complain about the most i feel like this
season it's going to be a little finger
there are a lot of little finger fans
out there that really want to see him
win the game of Thrones but the TV show
seems like it's throwing him under the
taunts of us so we'll see how that plays
out but I'm really excited to see what
they find in those dragonglass caves
underneath Dragonstone maybe they'll
find some old dragon eggs that have
petrified maybe some more Targaryen
flare because there's just so much
history there Targaryens have lived
there for hundreds of years and Daenerys
has absolutely no idea what's going on
so we as the audience will get to see
that for the first time as she's seeing
it for the first time - along with Jon
Snow but I know now that Jon Snow and
Daenerys have come together people were
kind of wondering when Jon's going to
learn he is a Targaryen how he's going
to learn I still think the brand is
going to be the one to literally convey
that information but I feel like this
show is going to tell us the audience
the whole story before the characters
find out
so like they'll have a flashback scene
or they'll have something to confirm who
Jon Snow's parents are what his status
is whether
not he's a bastard or a legitimate heir
to the Iron Throne but Jon Snow
engineers won't learn anything about
that until season 8 so that might be
frustrating but I'm okay with them
postponing a couple storylines - season
eight as long as they continue to pay
some of that mythology off without
brushing over it too quickly there were
a lot of people that were wondering why
they brushed over that high guard in
battle so far where are all the Tyrell
soldiers the way they explained it is
the reason why they chose to just skip
it was because they implies that the
Tyrells were terrible and making war
compared to the Lannisters who had
greater numbers because the tarly's had
switched sides and were just much more
well-equipped so you would have just
seen a version of them washing over the
Tyrell soldiers it would have been a
crazy amount of money to film all those
scenes so they just wanted to use that
money elsewhere
there will be big drawn-out battle
episodes but I feel like the vast
majority of their money went to the end
of the season when they fight the night
king up at eastwatch-by-the-sea so if
you wonder where all the money went it
went to dragons being bigger and it went
to that big final battle but let me know
in the comments what are you guys most
excited for next week and what will
happen is is all names a new giveaway
winner when I post my Q&A video tomorrow
there'll also be another Rick and Morty
promo but while you wait for everything
you can click here for my episode 3
video and you can click here to learn
all about dragon bonding thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight